luis sera aussi en lice à mort passé
grégory quartier bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le maire sortant et divers droite
donc de la commune vous serez candidat à
un deuxième mandat pour ce scrutin tête
de liste de continuons maurepas c'est
tout naturel pour vous après un premier
mandat de reproposer cette candidature
de continuer aussi des projets que vous
avez lancé oui c'est naturel parce qu'un
mandat c'est court et quand on s'inscrit
dans la durée il faut évidemment avoir
une prospective sur le long terme est en
effet un second mandat est nécessaire
pour voir j'allais dire se déployer tous
les projets et avec de nouveaux que nous
allons proposer donc en effet c'est
naturel on va parler de ses nouveaux
projets que vous proposez on rappelle le
contexte vous aviez été élu à maurepas
pour la première fois en 2014 après 25
ans de mandat à gauche avec georges
mougeot quel bilan faites vous de ce
premier mandat
quels sont les projets que vous avez pu
porter pendant ces six ans oh c'était un
mandat difficile avec évidemment les
collectivités qui ont été bousculés
financièrement amanda mais passionnant
mois qui suivent voient l'année à
maurepas voilà l'enfant de maurepas a pu
j'allais dire mettre en place ces
nombres de projets plus de 73 promesses
de campagne en 2014 95% ont été réalisés
et 220 projets supplémentaires ont été
portés et réalisé avec comme fierté la
rénovation complète de l'école du groupe
scolaire de la joe qui est terminé la
rénovation du centre ville
mais c'est également la rénovation des
voiries l'entretien du patrimoine
communal
lorsque j'ai hérité comme une situation
qui était catastrophique dans
l'entretien du patrimoine
on l'a vu avec la piscine qui va
continuer mon second mandat puisque la
livraison est prévue au printemps 2022
donc des gros projets lancés avec aussi
de répondre aux obligations de
construction de logements la révision du
plan local d'urbanisme où j'ai
sauvegardé les terres agricoles et
naturelles de maurepas en protégeant le
village et les quartiers existants mais
en engageant un renouvellement urbain
dans paris ouest avec la création d'un
écoquartier qui se construit
actuellement une entrée aussi au sein de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
on parlera tout à l'heure en 2014 vous
étiez candidat sous la bannière des
républicains
ce ne sera pas le cas pour ce prochain
scrutin puisque vous n'êtes plus
adhérent au parti aujourd'hui c'est sans
étiquette que vous allez vous présenter
face aux homos repas bien oui une liste
sans étiquette voilà je suis moi-même
mort passe bien depuis toujours et
j'aurai une liste de large rassemblement
avec des personnalités qui aiment leur
ville et qui veulent agir pour elle donc
j'allais dire les étiquettes compte peu
on a un socle de même valeur on a un
beau projet qui va comporter plus de 90
nouvelles propositions pour le mandat
2020 2026 c'est ce qui compte
donc pas de revendication d'investiture
on retrouve dans cette liste des
soutiens de la république en marche
par exemple il n'y aura pas de
revendication votre part j'ai le soutien
de plusieurs partis politiques déjà mais
en tout cas moi je serai divers droite
voilà mes convictions reste de la droite
moderne la droite centriste une droite
sociale mais dans une élection
municipale de dire le maire l'étiquette
qu'on ne peut ce qui compte c'est
surtout ses projets ce qu'il apporte
mort passe bien la vision de son
territoire et je crois que depuis six
ans maintenant je crois avoir fait mes
preuves et les mortagne à me connaissent
tels que je suis avec une équipe
renouvelée a priori pas d'hermann le
gall votre premier adjoint actuel sur
sur cette liste alors aujourd'hui en
malice tu sais elle va être renouvelé à
plus de 50%
l'objectif c'est d'avoir de nouvelles
énergies je suis quelqu'un qui n'aime
pas être sur ses habitudes
mais voilà je pars avec une équipe en
toute confiance
en tout voilà avec de l'expérience avec
du renouvellement aussi avec une équipe
renouvelée avec des jeunes qui veulent
s'investir et donc l'objectif aussi d'un
maire c'est de s'entourer de nouvelles
énergies pour continuer à faire bouger
la ville parce que j'ai réveillé
maurepas et ça c'est important je crois
que les mort patients le voit c'était
une ville endormie
la belle endormie donc nous avons une
belle ville et l'objectif c'est de
continuer à le réveiller à la dynamiser
pour faire en sorte que la vie soit
toujours attractive dans vos projets
pour la ville de maurepas il y en a un
qui ferait le lien entre ces deux
éventuel mandat si vous êtes donc réélu
c'est le centre aquatique vous en avait
parlé
le contrat de construction et de gestion
a été signé il faut maintenant mener à
bien la suite du projet oui alors le
contrat est signé depuis début janvier
je rappelle que mon opposition m'a fait
perdre deux ans sur ce projet avec une
multitude de recours qui a coûté une
fortune et la ville de maurepas ils ont
même été condamné d'ailleurs à 2300
euros d'amendé par le tribunal
administratif
aujourd'hui le permis de construire est
en cours d'instruction il faut cinq mois
le permis sera signé après les élections
municipales dont je le dis avec toute la
franchise que je dois avoir auprès dé
mort passe bien si que s'ils me font
confiance
le permis de construire s'assigner ils
les auront leur centre aqualudique en
en revanche si mes opposants sont élus
il n'y aura pas de piscine à maurepas et
ça je préfère être très clair
donc voilà c'est un enjeu aussi
important ça fait cinq ans qu'on
travaille sur le dossier c'est un beau
projet on est arrivé au bout
mais aujourd'hui voilà il ya besoin de
la continuité c'est pour ça que j'ai
aussi un slogan qui se continue à
maurepas continuons de faire la ville
dans la ce qu'elle est dans sa ville de
la ligne nouvelle mais aussi une ville
dynamique avec des projets qui sont
lancés et qui doivent continuer à voir
le jour
un autre projet justement la halle du
marché de maurepas qui a été ravagé par
un incendie
l'été dernier le but c'est de la
reconstruire oui cet incendie criminel
évidemment aujourd'hui on a une halle
provisoire qui est installée la
concertation publique avec les habitants
commencera après les élections
municipales et ensuite une fois la
concertation terminé on lancera un
marché public d'architectes pour nous
faire des propositions et ensuite lancer
les travaux pour une livraison je
l'espère d'ici fin 2022
début 2000 23 vous parlez de l'est
delajoux qui a été donc rénové
m'adresser celle de la malle me donne
que vous voudriez voir où il mangeait
mais priorité c'est la réussite des
enfants
on a mis plus de 9 millions d'euros sur
les 27 millions d'euros investis sur le
premier mandat pour rénover nos écoles
et mettre le paquet également sur la
petite enfance
aujourd'hui l'école de la balle me donne
au groupe scolaire de le mal me donne
est une école de 1968 et 69 qui
rencontre également des désordres
structurels qui n'a pratiquement jamais
été rénové et moi je ne suis pas
partisan du bricolage quand on fait les
choses on s'inscrit dans la durée et il
faut investir pour que les bâtiments
dure trente ou quarante ans aujourd'hui
on est arrivé au bout du groupe scolaire
de malmö donne il faut l'anticiper
donc on prévoira une large concertation
comme on l'a fait pour le groupe
scolaire de lajo pour engager sa
réhabilitation
de manière globale en lien que les corps
enseignant les parents d'élèves et les
agents de la ville et sur l'urbanisme
on peut évoquer on est obligé d'évoquer
cet écoquartier qui voit le jour
actuellement un mort pape sur le secteur
de paris-ouest paris-ouest aussi qui est
au coeur d'une réflexion sur comment
réinventer les zones commerciales à
saint quentin en yvelines paris ouest
c'est l'un des enjeux phares à maurepas
actuelle oui c'est l'avenir de la ville
dans les 20 ans qui viennent
nous avons une zone d'activité qui est
moribonde qui a un urbanisme qui est
d'été qui ne correspond pas j'allais
dire à la logique de développement
durable qu'on voudrait aujourd'hui et
demain d'ailleurs
donc on a été sélectionné par l'état
parce qu'on y construisait du logement
avec un éco quartier qui verra le jour
avec un espace médical une nouvelle
crèche parc urbain et l'idée c'est
d'engager une mutation en partenariat
aussi que la ville de coignières avec un
repositionnement économique des
commerces et je souhaiterais avoir un
positionnement porté vers les filières
vertes
l'agriculture urbaine de remettre de la
nature en ville de repenser les accès
les transports les mobilités bref que le
positionnement jaillir stratégiques de
paris ouest soit porté vers des
aménagements durables et aussi sur le
développement durable avec des
entreprises qui pourraient venir
s'installer sur
justement le l'écologie la filière verte
et pourquoi pas aussi la santé numérique
en 30 secondes je sais que c'est très
rapide
votre regard sur l'intégration de
maurepas dans l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
une intégration qui remonte maintenant à
2016 et oui et une intégration que je
souhaitais qui est naturel ou le savez
que maurepas faisait partie de la ville
nouvelle en 67
donc ce retour c'est un retour aux
sources aujourd'hui avec les services de
l'agglomération ça se passe très bien on
a des compétences qui ont été transférés
aujourd'hui maintenant il faut qu'on
aille plus loin dans la proximité la
réactivité
ça va beaucoup mieux qu'auparavant voilà
moi j'ai un regard en tout cas positif
il faut continuer avec des gros projets
structurants qui sont portées par
l'agglomération et qui est beaucoup de
mauriciens et vos prochains rendez vous
dans le cadre de cette campagne des
municipales alors d une réunion de
quartier qui sera prévu encore avant le
premier tour après c'est beaucoup de
rendez vous sur des marchés tous les
mercredis matins et les samedis matins
du porte à porte tous les jours et voilà
on continue une rencontre auprès dé mort
passe bien et avec une présentation de
toutes les propositions fil de l'eau
parce que a contrario à mes adversaires
je commence déjà à faire des
propositions alors je suis dans un état
d'esprit positif constructif
ma liste est bouclée donc maintenant il
ya plus qu'à comme on dit merci à
grégory christ il est maire sortant de
maurepas candidats de continuons
maurepas et dans cette ville se sont
également déclarés deux conseillers
municipaux d'opposition qui conduiront
des listes différentes ismail havane
pour maurepas dynamique et solidaire
ainsi que la candidature de michel chapa